ý lộn ờ
này à
Ê
mày thì như các bạn đã thấy tiêu đề thì
khi mình bị lừa cái hôm nay mình không
làm việc mấy mà mình à
khi ngủ với thư giãn là nhiều và
cho đến bây giờ mình vẫn muốn thế Mình
vẫn Vợ muốn hôm nay cho mình một cái
ngày nghỉ ngơi chứ không ạ
anh
Bởi vì nếu các bạn thấy giọng mình đang
hơi bị ốm tí nhưng mà buổi dậy vẫn còn
dậy nhà mà hôm nay mình sẽ dậy một cái
liên quan đến vụ án mà cũng chưa giao
lưu tâm sự với các bạn chứ không Không
chạy cốt ngày hôm nay
A
gọi là cũng phù hợp cho các bạn nào mà
đang cậu đang theo cốt thì không bắt kỳ
tục tôi cốt Bởi vì tôi cốt đôi khi mấy
bạn còn đang còn đang chập chững ở những
cái bữa trước tôi thấy có vài bạn là như
thế
ừ ừ
qua về chuẩn hóa ở bên atwell rồi nhưng
mà mình không dậy chuyên về cái đấy bởi
vì cái đấy thì à bản chất mình không
chuyên và bản chất là mình nó có từng nó
đó là thực tế thì rất nhiều lúc của
chúng ta phải chấp nhận là sự không trần
hóa để mà mình lưu thừa dữ liệu nhưng bù
lại thì
đỡ tốn bước về câu lệnh truy vấn về
những câu lệnh roi mà mình sẽ gộp chung
vào trong một bạn Vân Em ơi mình đang bị
ốm
không phải bị ko bít mình nghĩa như thế
với thằng chưa Mình phải có biến mất rồi
thì mình chỉ đang bị ốm với cậu ạ
ờ ờ đi địt lần đầu tiên tôi thấy bể bơi
xịn là như thế nào ạ bể bơi có điều hòa
ở trong phòng thay đồ người đang ướt
sũng tự nhiên vào cái điều hòa lạnh vãi
so với ôm luôn à
chào anh ngày lại ngày nay em mới đi bảo
đưa học kỳ 6 tháng để chuyên tâm vô học
khóa của anh
Anh
hãy để chắc là tôi sẽ kể về câu chuyện
là
anh tâm sự này trước đã như đã thấy hôm
nay em mình chửi ở tâm sự nhiều lúc ạ
Các bạn có gì cứ tâm sự thì
Ừ thì nói chút à với tôi thì tôi thấy
mình vẫn may mắn sao rất nhiều bạn rất
nhiều Bạn bây giờ vẫn đang nhắn tin cho
tôi là cậu muốn theo nửa thì muốn theo
ngành này nữa không có việc
anh
bạn đấy vẫn mông lung như trò đùa khi
học ở trên trường ngày Môn này mà thực
tế thời mà tôi học ở trên trường thì tội
đúng mông linh như trò đùa thật
Ừ đấy cả tôi kể cả tôi làm được việc nhá
thì cả tôi được điểm cao cái gì đó tôi
vẫn thực sự không hoàn lại thích ngày
đâu chứ đừng nói những cái bạn học ở
trường bây giờ gặp nhiều thầy cô của
những tạo sự khó khăn Nói chung nhiều
yếu tố nữa Nhờ bạn còn mới tiếp cận bây
giờ mới thực sự mới tiếp cận với với máy
tính được ạ thì còn khó nữa ạ
Internet từ bé thông như tôi đó tôi cửa
trốn học cô bé đi nét với cậu thế
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà chúng ta có thể khởi điểm
khác nhau nhưng mà quan trọng là chúng
ta có dám đi lâu dài một cái gì đó mà
chúng ta kiên quyết với nó không Ví dụ
là trong ngành này tôi thường anh Định
mấy ông không phải ai cũng xem được ngày
này nhưng mà tôi đang dạy mấy ông này
ông ấy về thủ xem đây là một lựa chọn
đúng không ạ còn lựa chọn gì đó mà miễn
phí nó chỉ tốn thời gian với ông Thôi từ
nay gian rồi Nhớ sạc nhưng mà viết các
bạn không miễn phí mà ông cũng sẽ không
ân hận thì mấy so với kiểu đi học ở B có
ông đi học nghề nhiều nơi xong rồi nó
không đem lại kết quả thì ông sẽ lãng
phí không ạ
ừ ừ
tôi còn nói chuyện với bạn là con gái về
cái vụ mà tôi có nói mấy ông từ bụi
trước nữa đó là
Ồ
tôi định là có hai dự định một dự định
là Thứ nhất là tôi sẽ chia sẻ tài liệu
của tôi cho mấy ông ạ Cho những ông là
đã xác nhận được đi thực tập Còn đi làm
đấy ạ Mấy ông nhớ bạ thì tôi đã mua khá
nhiều khá nhiều thì cũng đúng bởi vì
cũng phải là tầm à 6 đến 7 khóa học
dazzle với equal
vô địch chia sẻ mấy cái đấy Mấy ông
không nên chia sẻ một cách rộng rãi nhờ
tôi định chia sẻ cho một vài ông kiểu
dạng là có inbox riêng mình Nhưng mà
Xin chào bạn ấy bảo là thế thì nó liên
quan khá nhiều vi phạm bản quyền cũng
như là kiểu à không tôn trọng tác giả
cũng như là về sau mà là sử về sau mà
tôi nổi lên tự nhiên nữa cái đấy nó sẽ
để lại mưa một cái gì đó cứ cho 10 phút
à cái kiểu cứ thế đấy xấu là về sau à à
anh ta thấy bữa ra để đệm màu cậu để mà
chỗ kiện Tôi trả bạn có thể thế nên
thành Nếu mà tôi hướng đến về sau là
người có tiếng nói và Lê Văn thì không
nên được làm thế thì chắc là tôi đang
ngồi chơi cái cho cũng có cũng đúng coi
là như vi phạm bản quyền như một cách
chính đáng còn là ăn cắp chất xám như
một cái chính đáng là tôi sẽ phải học
tất cả đống tài liệu đấy sau dậy lại mấy
ông đúng na ná như thế thì
thư cá Thế lại hợp pháp bằng cái gì đó
ngọn
ờ ờ tiếp theo đó là
anh ra đối với tôi đối với tôi nhá
ờ ờ tôi tôi dậy cho mấy ông miễn phí như
này đúng bạn và lúc đầu tôi bị chia sẻ
tài liệu cho mấy ông miễn phí như thế
Tôi chỉ sợ thứ nhất là việc là ông chia
sẻ nó cách bừa bãi thì nó sẽ dễ nó không
tốt cho tác giả thứ hai là
Ừ thứ hai nó là kiểu
nói chung là tôi sợ mấy ông đem bán gì
đó để vu lợi cho bản thân chứ tôi không
ngại việc là chia sẻ tại điều mấy ông
thì việc các bạn thì rất nhiều người có
thể đang định mới đi làm hoặc thậm chí
em vẫn nó còn là sinh viên thì số tiền
vài triệu về bỏ ra mua một cái ebook hay
một cái khóa học gì đó nó khá là đắt Mà
chưa biết được thực sự là khóa học về cô
phù hợp với họ hay không Nói Vân đồng
loạn như tài liệu so sánh hơn tiếng Anh
rồi thì
Ừ thì bà đặc biệt là tài liệu của rất
rất nhiều thứ ra hồi trước hồi trước
nghe Hồi trưa tôi đọc cái có một cái
video nói về vụ là về về nó kiện hằn
Harvard à và mới đại học lớn đó là
chuyện lời tri thức thì đáng lẽ phải nên
là miễn phí để chia sẻ cho cộng đồng và
chia sẻ cho thế hệ sau để thế hệ sau
Tiếp tục phát triển chứ không phải là
nên là cậu nên giữ khư khư khối trước là
các trường đại học lớn ở Mỹ là gần như
sẽ chỉ cung cấp tài liệu cho sinh viên
của họ thậm chí còn phải như như thế nào
đấy giờ khó là tiếp cận được nguồn kiến
kiến thức đấy Chẳng hạn Nếu hiểu rõ ngọn
thì thực tế là đương nhiên ở cái này nó
có
ô tô Không mẹ nói bảo là tôi khuyên tất
cả mình thấy người ấy bỏ sữa sáng làm
với anh miễn phí đương nhiên là họ cũng
lên được à tên được tài trợ nhưng mà mới
sinh viên của mình với sinh viên nói
chung về cái thế hệ sau nói chung và
đương nhiên là họ cũng nên dễ dàng tiếp
cận được kiến thức đối ngoại
Ừ cái nói chung và vấn đề nó hơi bị hay
chiều có người cũng cho cái này cũng có
cái đúng có người
khi có người nói cái khác cũng đúng giả
sử Giả sử nhé là sự là bạn kia bạn cũng
nói là có
thứ nhất là nếu là cái gì miễn phí đôi
khi chúng ta không trân trọng ngày gần
nhất thứ hai đó là là công sức họ của
những người khác bỏ ra thì nên là hủy mì
ông gần như là mình phải bỏ một cái gì ở
xứng đáng thì mới đạt được cái điều đấy
nhưng mà
Ừ
nhưng mà bản chất thì khi mà bảo là bỏ
vài triệu ra để mua mấy cái tài liệu đặc
biệt là sinh viên mới ông thì chả ít ông
nào sẵn sàng có thể bỏ ra được ngoài lấy
tiền để mà thấy được toàn thân tôi phải
khi tôi đi làm nên may mà tôi được may
mà cậu hơi mà tôi đã ra trường cái tôi
được làm thầy đi dạy rồi đấy cũng dư dả
tiền đâu mà có tiền mua tài liệu chứ
không thì chẳng biết bao giờ tôi mới có
tiền để mua tài liệu bây giờ tính cả khi
mà phải làm đẹp như thế này rồi thì
lương của tôi cũng chỉ tầm à 1.000 đô
thì cũng không dư giả mấy để mua tài
liệu luôn cái nào như thế cũng nó đợi
giảm giá rồi mua 12 khóa học chưa bây
giờ để mà mua rất nhiều khóa học để cập
nhật hình kiến thức thì rất khó tài liệu
thì càng ngày càng nhiều như nó khá đắt
Ừ tôi thấy tao bắt một phần là cũng bởi
vì à hình như là nó nghĩ rằng à Ít người
mua và một người mua đông khi chia sẻ
rộng rãi hàng là nó sẽ bán giá khá đắt
cho dù thì cả mình có nhập mã làm giá kể
cả mình và cho bảo là mình đang dùng
merdu sinh viên thì giá nó vỡ đắt nhà
tôi nghĩ là
Ừ tôi không Tôi hiểu nghe nè ở Việt Nam
mình nói chung thì tự nhiên mày của mình
Mình vẫn đang thoải mái rồi cái vụ bản
quyền và
sản phẩm trí tuệ người khác nhưng
thế nhưng với cá nhân tôi thì ạ tôi vẫn
ủng hộ cái quan điểm đó là trí thức thì
phải lên chia sẻ và nên dễ tiếp cận đấy
là lý do tôi dạy cho mày ông rất nhiều
cái miễn phí và tôi thấy tao lúc đầu tôi
vẫn muốn mà chia sẻ lại lựa chọn mấy ông
ga miễn phí bởi vì à
với những hôm nào muốn học thì ra đấy là
mùng nguồn kiến thức thêm một cái ra là
ổn để cho bé uống thể kéo thích cận chứ
Bây giờ Bây giờ thì cả ông nằm chun eo
chưa làm Sino thì đương nó cũng chỉ trên
tầm 10 triệu chẳng hạ ông không thể một
Tháo
à Không để chi 12 triệu ra để mua tài
liệu được rồi Ông còn sợ nhiều cái nữa
không biết nhiều không hoàn cảnh khó
khăn không phải đầy đủ lắm còn say sợ
nữa
để dành tiền đi chơi bạn gái hả hả à à
được ra là là
khi họ thoải mái ở mua những cái tài
liệu đấy Nó kiểu bị ngừa cái nghĩa là
người cần thì người khó thích cận con
người không cần thì họ dễ tiếp cận thành
ra là kiểu
Ừ anh ra giống như kiểu tài liệu chỉ
dành cho người giàu ấy nhà tao không
thích cái khái niệm này đó lắm tri thức
thì bạn chắc nó không phân biệt giàu
nghèo đó dành cho tất cả mọi người dành
cho mọi đối tượng gì nó méo đương nhiên
là nó nên có cái giá của nó
không thể nói miễn phí một cách dễ dàng
được nhưng mà Mấy ông bản chất là học
học thì mới ông cũng đã nhập vào trong
đầu rồi
Anh ấy tiếp theo
a Nhân tiện nói với cả đấy thì nó liên
quan đến việc là bạn đấy bảo là nếu mà
bây giờ cho cho mấy ông tài liệu thì
không khác gì cho con cá gà như là đối
với thử Cái Huệ nó hơi bị sai đúng ạ Rõ
ràng và cho tài liệu thì mấy ông Nguyễn
phải đọc tài liệu và áp dụng treo tôi
thì cho tài liệu là cho cái cần chứ
không phải con cá đầu nhọn cũng giống
như là khi mà tôi dạy cho mấy ông tất cả
những cái này tôi là đang cung cấp cho
ông đó cái cần nhiều hơn là con Cha tui
ở Nhiều lúc tôi hướng đến một giải quyết
một bài toán cụ thể nhưng mà ông rõ ràng
thấy à là cái cách hướng cách xử lý vấn
đề của tôi đó tôi đang hướng dẫn mà ông
cách câu hai cái gì đó hơn là cậu hướng
đến hàng một cái kết quả cụ thể một cái
chi tiết không ạ
dù tổng kết lại tâm sự vừa rồi Chỉ đơn
giản ngắn gọn là nhớ là chả tôi không
thể chia sẻ tài liệu trong mấy ông được
bởi vì họ vẫn liên quan Bạn liên quan
bản quyền một phần liên quan về sau ở
Nếu mà tôi muốn xây dựng hình ảnh này
chắc là đúng là tôi không không nên chia
sẻ cái đấy vì nó vi phạm được họ nó vẫn
ở vi phạm gì đó Để sau có người kiện thì
chịu
thế nhở cho tôi không chia sẻ được à
đấy thì tôi sẽ dạy cho mấy ông mấy ông
cũng yên tâm Tôi sẽ dạy con theo dễ hiểu
nhà Ông thấy hai cái tát tôi đang ghi mà
đây ông ạ chứa những khóa học tôi mua ở
bên Stark status đấy cái khóa học này
những cái video có thủ đoạn II
có lẽ tiếp theo là hôm nay thì ở tôi bảo
tôi không dậy thì mấy mà hôm nay tôi sẽ
chia sẻ cho mấy ông về cái đồ án trang
web nói trường của tôi từng làm
Ừ cái này cần chưa khoe thì cũng đúng
Nhưng mà cũng hướng dẫn cho mấy ông kiểu
dạo à từ ông rất nhiều ông đang làm còn
đến nhà trường cũng như là nói chung và
bài toán nghiệp vụ là nhiều hơn kết hợp
việc là liên quan đến tình chấm công các
thứ thứ nữa bởi vì có nhóm Hôm trước làm
chấm công cứ loạn hết cả lên cái thì tôi
sẽ chia sẻ cho mấy ông cho bộ hôm nay
Cái này là dữ liệu cũng dữ liệu cũ từ
2120 rồi Thành ra
nếu xem bảo cho anh kia à
một ngày nên tập trung hợp lập trình bao
nhiêu tiếng đi hợp lý với anh ra thì cái
này tôi không Tôi không đo thời gian này
mình học là trình bao lâu rồi nói chung
nhà có những ngày tôi cảm thấy giống như
ví dụ hôm nay tôi cảm thấy rất không
muốn cốt Không nên ngồi cốt béo cũng nên
thế còn nếu mà Mấy ông cả tháng mà mếu
không muốn ngồi cốc thì chả lâu không
nên hợp ngày ngày rồi Như đã nói là rồi
khi cậu ta vỡ đam mê cốc nhá Không ạ
nhưng có những ngày cả mình mệt mỏi mình
đau đầu nói dối mới nghỉ ngơi cho phép
mình nghỉ ngơi các thử thứ sau đó thì
những ngày hôm sau phải đủ nhờ mục mặt
ngồi cày thôi ông ạ nhưng mà làm thế
trong tôi vẫn luôn để mình trong trạng
thái thoải mái thì sẽ cậu làm mọi thứ
đều ô còn hơn ông ép bản thân mình làm
một cái gì đó thì nó sẽ hiểu khó chịu
nữa bọn
số ngày nghỉ ngơi hơi nhiều á xuống lại
nghỉ ngơi nhiều thì bù lại ông phải làm
những cái ngày ông làm ông phải dơ năng
suất giống như có một ngày tôi thật
Nghĩa hồi trước tôi có thưởng như thế gỗ
điển hình a điểm hình A là Ừ tôi từng
nói mail mà Thứ Bảy Chủ Nhật đối Tôi
không phải ngày nghỉ không ạ Nhưng mà
tuần theo tôi ốm mình Thứ bảy chủ nhật
tôi vẫn là ngày nghỉ ấy đã hiển nhiên nó
ngày nghỉ rồi nhưng mà Bình thường ấy
với tôi không phải nhà nghỉ nhé á
ừ ừ
à Tôi nghĩ nói cho tôi nghỉ thứ bảy chủ
nhật vừa rồi tôi thứ hai về rồi tôi lên
đôi làm Nói chung là toàn bộ gần như
xong hết công việc rồi Hôm nay tôi đã
nghỉ à
ông làm được hiệu quả ông làm hồ sơ nộp
thì không sao cả tạm biệt cái ngành này
nhàng
không cần phải cũng còn deride của nó
nhưng mà không cần kiểu tạo ra kiểu
anh ngày nào cũng phải là cái giống
Nghĩa xong việc là xong việc làm loạn nó
sẽ ổn hơn
ở
đầu tiên thì đây là cây Trang vào đầu
tiên ngắm được nghỉ số điện thoại nha
em cho số điện thoại đi rồi đi làm cho
mày ông đi số điện thoại được thầy cô
nhé Đây là cái trang web của tôi trang
web và Anh ở phần mềm quản lý nhà trường
cái này là cái này là giao diện nhiều
ông sẽ để quen với giao diện này lợn
amin le le với tôi có cho là cái ra cập
nhật ở đây từ Khuyến xử đấy
cách trị giá về cập nhật đâu vậy
ở Nhật phép đúng ạ
Ê mấy ông sẽ thấy riêng ngày mai luôn
rồi Nó rất là nhiều rồi
khi họ rất rất nhiều trong đấy còn rất
nhiều nữa à
ở đợt đầu tiên thì khi mà mới
liệu thì mày không sẽ thấy à sở liệu của
tôi bao nhiêu Bạn ấy thì K nó còn liên
quan và những bạc của bên khác nữa không
đi cập ở đây để khỏi có rất nhiều bạn
đây ạ
à à
anh nhiều lắm
Ờ đầu tiên là giả sử là khi mà mới vào
đầu năm này chúng ta sẽ tạo khóa này
đúng không ạ
từ khóa nó tự suy này cơ bởi vì à về sau
mình không đậm đến nhiều tạo khóa ngay
sau đó tạo lớp cho khóa
khi nghe Tôi có cái trò là tạo nhanh
kiểu dạ dày Kiều Ừ từ 1 cho đến năm này
mã lớp là ví dụ là dù là lập trình thì
sẽ gọi lợn là tê này tên love tên lớp
của tôi thì sẽ ra khẩu
lập trình
ạ
sau đó lấy chìa khóa khóa bậy ngay sáng
ạ và
chương trình đào tạo sẽ lập trình khi
tôi thêm mà tôi sẽ tạo lớp lập trình 01
lập trình không hay lập trình cho đến
lập trình 07 lập trình 05 ngày cậu thế
và thêm chữ K7 ở đằng sau nữa họ sẽ kiểu
dạng như này
ở đây
tiếp theo là làm chương trình đào tạo
này
cho thuê nhà tạ đào tạo để biết được là
một chương trình đào tạo Nó sẽ có những
môn gì
chị sẽ bỏ thì chi tiết chuyên nghiệp
ở đâu tiêu tại nhìn đạo sau tạo cả
truyện trường tôi trước có liên kết với
bên Cao đẳng nghe nữa thành ra có tận 2
chương trình đào tạo cơ gọi hai bên nó
vừa thôi
ở đây tôi kiểu dạng là có cả học kỳ đó
ghi chú xong rồi chi kiểu gì em ôn lại
là mua mình sẽ phải tạo thêm môn ở đây
cái không có thể tích vào đây để để thêm
một cái chương trình đào tạo vào cái một
môn ở trên đào tạo đấy chắc ạ ạ
ánh xạ trong ở tạo nhưng cái này cha mày
không biết thì bỏ qua đi
ở trong vào khi ở mình có môn rồi lắm ạ
tiếp theo mình có sinh viên à
Ừ thì mình sẽ chọn khóa này là sự ngay
trọn khóa
Ê này
nhìn sẽ toàn bộ sinh viên có thêm mới
một sinh viên như này nhưng mà nhưng mà
hồi đấy bị mất công nó không ạ Đây mình
sẽ chơi có trò là mình sẽ à
ờ ờ Tôi nhớ là cái vụ thêm sinh viên
[âm nhạc]
có thêm sinh viên đầu nhà
em nhớ có cái vụ thêm sinh viên theo à
Excel
khi nghe tôi không nhớ nó đâu nữa rồi
cho lợn đi
ừ ừ
đi
theo tôi nhớ hồi nãy cổ bụng thêm sinh
viên anh Sao trưa nay có nhiều á
là lời tiêu mà
không sửa giao diện máy nhưng mà da spa
nhiều lắm
Anh ở chung à Ok vừa rồi là liên quan
đến ví dụ là giọt sự thêm sinh viên các
thứ sau đó thì mình sẽ nhập điểm cho
sinh viên ý là không có câu Và quên quên
điểm danh sinh viên thì sẽ điểm danh
sinh viên trước đã sửa hiệu sẽ chọn khóa
chọn lớp chọn môn như này những cái chọn
lớp chọn môn chọn khóa này thì mình sẽ
phải ở phân công giảng dạy đã phải phân
công dạy học đã thì mình sẽ phân công
kiểu nhà
cách làm kẹo hồ đây tôi bị cuồng ấy mua
đồ mà mày không thấy tao cuồng mua đồ
cái dịch mua đồ cả không nên ngày lắm
Em hãy sẽ chọn có môn có một kiểu nhà
nếu không sẽ xảy ra
Ừ tôi có thể có tích vào là tức chọn tất
cả các lớp học học môn này là sự cô ấy
kia mỗi môn này cho cả hai khóa đấy hay
là thể chọn cụ thể tất cả các lớp tất cả
lớp này nó sẽ theo nó sẽ theo
khi khai chương trình đào tạo bằng cách
khóa Mày chẳng hạn thế mà vật ấy đi làm
lại xong thì thôi Hãy cởi hết ngồi này
tôi nhớ con có xem chi tiết của theo
thầy cô nào cơ lại ẩn đi hết rồi chúng
tôi ẩn đi một vài cái khá nhiều à
Vì sao đó thì mình mới có điểm danh mình
sẽ có điểm danh như thế này
đề tài là sữa tôi chọn một cái điểm danh
nhé
à à
Ừ thì nó sẽ hiện ra cái này lịch sử có
sẵn rồi
chị sẽ hiển thị ra là ờ thực tế là nếu
mày hiển thị ra chữ đi học hay chữ nghỉ
học hay mày cái chữ dài dòng nhiều quái
nó rất là bị đau mắt nên thành ra là
chơi kiểu viết tắt kiểu ngay thôi thấy
màu người dùng sẽ dễ nhìn cho hoàn toàn
bộ về giao diện cũng như là mày cái tính
năng này thì lại là thầy của tôi là thầy
thầy có tầm nhìn và thấy hợp làm bia đây
nghĩa là busines lý
tất cả phân tích xe mà người dùng thực
sự cần gì xã hội thầy nói tôi tôi chỉ
được làm thôi tôi Hồi đấy tôi không phân
tích mấy mà tôi giống tách hơn làm cái
kiểu này không thấy Nhìn cảnh này nó dễ
nhìn hơn này trước quan hơn thì số Bùi
nghỉ ở đây này
à mà kết luận và học lại không này về
thích ở đây để chọn như thế này toàn bộ
cao giá Xuất Kích hết à bằng J hết ấy
rồi ấn đây để xóa một cái gì đó này hoặc
có thêm mới này
ở đây nhờ đây điểm nhanh lên Giàu giáo
phụ Thế còn bên giáo viên thì sao giáo
viên thì tôi sẽ có là à
em không nhớ ghê đấy à
xe ngựa cái tài khoản này
À hôm nay bây giờ tôi đã gì nhé tôi đổi
lại thành 1 2 3 hết đi à
đi đợi tím
à à
anh có thể một khi mà giáo viên điểm
danh vào ra ạ vào truy cập vào nó sẽ có
ít hơn so với giáo vụ không ạ hoa có xem
lịch sử điểm danh này xem lịch sử để ổn
định hoàn toàn thể sửa lại cái điểm danh
cũ
em sửa lại điện máy cũ tưởng như này
nhưng mà Đấy ra sửa con còn khi mà thêm
mới ở sẽ ở nhà
thì nó sẽ lấy mặc định ngày hôm nay kiểm
tra ở điểm danh nhà chưa Này số buổi Đã
dậy rồi này thì kiểu gì này và Hồi đấy
tôi còn quy ước là một môn học bao nhiêu
giờ nên còn bao nhiêu giờ được phép điểm
danh với Liên quan chấm công nữa đấy sao
mặc định là thích được đi học hết này có
thể tích và nghỉ hai cái gì đó Đấy sau
đó thì có thể bấm vào những cái nút này
để tự động nhập giờ ra xử Giả sử là bây
giờ mặc định là buổi tối nên mặc định ở
dậy sẽ dạy ca tối cũng không phải sẽ
hiển thị giờ khác bây giờ này cũng trẻ
hot cô thôi nho khi bấm vào thì đi Bấm
vào nó tự động tìm nhanh hộ Nói chung là
làm cho người dùng đỡ phải điệp
Ừ đúng ạ đấy Hồi trước là thời lượng
giải ra rồi cho Bấm cho điện Bây giờ thì
mặc định là là không không cần gọi điện
nữa ghi chú có thể ghi chú thêm nhóm này
và ở đây thì có thêm quy định là là
không được sớm hơn giờ bắt đầu mà không
muộn hơn giờ kết thúc 30 phút để tránh
việc là điểm danh Minh ta tinh ấy Và khi
mà điểm danh xong thì sẽ hiển thị ra đã
điểm danh ở đây là sự tôi cho bến xe này
đó chị xin nào đi học đấy Huế Hồi đấy
với tháng này thì sẽ hiển thị điểm danh
này nhớ với thằng trước thì sẽ hiển thị
là tre con tất cả ông chị ạ là xác nhận
đã điểm đã được chấm công và hôm nào ấy
thích vào để mà thì tổng số giờ đã dạy
tháng trước để tính ra lương cái chích
on tất cả tỉnh nha lương ở bên công ty
Châu phía cả như thế đấy
Anh trông thi cũng sẽ Thị Màu nào là như
nào đấy cho khi mà khi có thể nó kiểm
tra chứ con nghĩa là kiểm tra xem tháng
trước mình đã dạy bao nhiêu giờ bao
nhiêu lớp để ra được số tiền số tiền
mình được nhận số giờ mình đã dạy nhưng
số tiền mình cũng nhận nó bọn đấy
danh mà có thể làm rất là phức tạp như
thế thôi ông ạ
khi mình alo điểm danh xong thì mình sẽ
lập danh sách khi mình sẽ dựa theo những
cái tiêu chí mà mà rụng ra sự là
ở lớp đấy đã đưa điểm danh rồi đấy ấy
cô giáo sư của là Trương cần một trăm
phần trăm này thì được thi à Còn không
Mình sẽ là có thể cắm đi vì chậm học phí
cái gì đó cho phép sinh viên đề thi còn
nếu mà không cho phép phép sinh viên thi
thì ấn vào đây để mà loại sinh viên đấy
nó sẽ bị đẩy xuống dừa như thế này Đấy
nó sẽ có rất nhiều đây nó sẽ có cập nhật
à
ở đây là mặc định là môn này chị thi
thực hành còn nếu môn thi thực hành cả
lý thuyết thì sẽ bị đầy đủ đây có hiển
thị à Hồi đấy là có tôi ấn thông báo ở
đây là tôi không những là thông báo qua
qua mail ko ah
à mà còn thông báo qua Facebook về Hồi
đấy tôi làm Facebook rất nhiều như hồi
đấy là Hồi đấy tôi còn phải dùng Token
của người dùng mà đẩy lên các nhóm và
phải nhập ID của group vào trên vào theo
ID group theo lớp đấy thì sẽ tự động tự
động là đăng thông báo trên nhóm trên
Facebook nữa đấy nhớ Bây giờ thì à
Hà Nội dung và phòng Facebook Ngọ làm
khá nhiều với cái vụ đấy nên là tôi gỡ
rồi chứ hồi trước ở tôi còn làm tự động
gửi mail cho tất cả các sinh viên này
gửi mail các thầy cô này tự động đăng
lên nhóm trên Facebook nữa đấy à
tiện nhất người dùng không ạ
sau khi mà điểm khi mà thi lại xong các
thứ thứ rồi đúng không ạ thì tiếp theo
mình sẽ nhập điểm nhập điểm thì sẽ là
kiểu hiển thị ra lớp mình nhập thôi sẽ
kiểu như hai chị lần 1 lần 2 như này
nhập cái mặc định là lần 1 lần 2 nếu là
nếu nhập lần 2 rồi sẽ hiển thị lần 3
nhập làm ba nếu có thể thấy sau khi nhận
nhầm nhập xong hết rồi mình sẽ có là
tổng kết đĩa
Ừ đấy tổng kết điểm này tôi sẽ xuất ra
cái file Excel hôi đấy là ngồi đây là
bên ra vụ căn cứ điều lấy sẽ số ta phải
Excel để mà để mà thống kê cái gì đó
hai tay qua đời tôi làm đoạn này diệt
mặn nhiều quá thì tính toán tính toán
Xem thằng là đủ điều kiện tốt nghiệp hay
không thì là lâu quá nên thành ra tôi cứ
nhưng ra quyết về làm cái vụ này thôi
tôi cứ bảo người dùng Đợi 10 giây để tôi
tính toán xong rồi tôi bu đội tô màu cho
những cái thằng nào mà có vấn đề này
không hiểu sau đó mình sẽ tay phải xem
người bắt người dùng Đợi 10 giây sau cái
đã ra kia chắc là nó chạy xong hết đã
Ừ rồi đấy Nói chung là làm cốt còn non
lắm nhưng mà tự mình cố tình bình thường
mà
giống ở đây đồ ăn hay và đồ ăn ba bảo
tôi lại cốt bằng tags
anh đón hài cốt bằng pp thuần của vỡ mồm
luôn Xong rồi đến khi nó sang level ổn
hơi nhờ dùng giao hàng ra cút ra cút kít
dài phải chưa
top 10 giây lâu thế
anh alo
xe tải nó sẽ xuất tại Cafe Excel với cái
trang này nó dài quá
à à
anh em đâu sẽ thấy ngay ta sẽ hiển thị
ra số mol nợ này những cái mô nợ còn bao
nhiêu này tiện trục Bình bao nhiêu này
lại kén ngay ok chưa Đấy tiếp theo là sẽ
Ừ tôi sẽ nói qua về cái vụ mà vừa nãy
tôi bảo đó là chấm công giáo viên thì sẽ
mình sẽ chỉ hiển thị ra đây những cái
khóa những cái lớp mà thực sự là là cái
tháng và cái năm này có xuất hiện điểm
ra anh đệm và chấm công đấy nên thì đã
các lớp về thôi phải chị hiển thị ra các
lớp mà đã được mình hết tích trước ở đây
để người dùng hiệu là đã đã làm chậm đã
xác nhận làm công cái này lớp môn này
rồi để đỡ phải nick lại mới nữa để kiểm
tra được không đấy thì chị đã làm cho
con này để cậu ngay đó sẽ có thể cập
nhật mặc định còn hiền địa thứ Bởi vì
thực sự người dùng Nhìn cái này nó không
phải nick thêm một lần nữa thì mới bị
mới hình dung được đã Hôm nay là thứ mấy
là sửa người dùng chỉ nhớ là thầy này
chỉ dạy và thứ Năm chẳng Bạn hãy dậy Ba
ơi chắc ạ ấy sẽ chị ra hết ở đây như thế
này có thêm mới hả ta xóa đi và Vân rồi
đấy và mình thể gửi mail để mà xác nhận
e mail xác nhận ngày thì bên Giáo viên
sẽ phải vào xác nhận ở bên giáo viên đã
sau đó thì giáo viên xác nhận xong thì
nó sẽ nhìn thấy cái xác nhận bên này
xong rồi xong rồi giao vụ sẽ sẽ cập nhật
phải in phát cô ấy khi mà giáo viên đã
xác nhận xong hết rồi đấy
Ê mấy ông hiểu bài toán liên con tiền
nong có phải như lại chứ không phải làm
cái kiểu như mấy ông cậu làm thì đĩa
như nào lấy vợ đấy nó phải như thế này à
Ừ tôi còn im điểm tốt nghiệp nữa xong
rồi à ừ ừ tôi còn in nghiệm tốt nghiệp
để mà in Nam bạn nó đó nữa nên đại khái
như thế
vừa tôi chơi à
Ừ nó là trang web quản lý nhà trường của
tôi đấy tôi làm cái đấy xong là hơn cũng
tầm 25 vừa làm vừa trịch một mình tôi
chạy thôi
bao gồm cả thời gian Tôi vừa đi dạy và
thời gian tôi làm ở chung nhà kiểu
thầy hay là do vụ của yêu cầu gì thì tôi
đã nuôi làm còn không gì không làm gì cả
rồi chúng mà Bởi vì trang web này mấy
ông thầy đó toàn bộ tất cả sai lên thì
thực ra chỉ trong vòng vài tháng thợ xây
xong rồi nhờ cần cập nhật thêm tính năng
gì cả các thứ thứ thì thỉnh thoảng tôi
cập nhật thêm vào nha nó sẽ nó sẽ ngoài
được là bài toán à à
thì nó sẽ có hai khái niệm thì ra đây
Thời gian làm và thời gian thực tế của
phần mềm này hoạt động thời gian thực tế
phần mềm hoạt động này rất là lâu nó
kiểu
A gọi là có quyền sử mới khái niệm Tây
tiếng Anh thì nhớ tiếng Việt thì không
nhiều lắm Nói chung à cái nói chung là
cái phần mềm này thì nó chạy đưa vào
hoạt động lâu rồi đấy nó vẫn nổi Đến bây
giờ trường vẫn không ấy chứ cậu sang
trường kêu là không mua lại phần mềm của
tôi nhưng vẫn luôn
không hiểu Đấy bà hồi nãy tôi có bị rảnh
thôi còn làm Chơi chơi cái nữa cho sinh
viên thôi nhưng mà gỡ gỡ rồi
Ừ anh sáng môn học Thực ra cái ánh sáng
môn học đó chẳng qua liên kết giữa môn
của bên tôi với môn Minh cao đẳng Nghề
ấy mà cái cho ông không cần quan tâm đâu
đấy tôi làm cho trang của sinh viên là
sẽ Nghị định như thế này rất hay rất
nhiều trang trường của mấy ông cũng khi
không có nó hiển thị ở đây đổi thông tin
của ông này hiển thị Hồi ấy tôi bị rảnh
thôi hiển thị ra cái chỗ sinh ngày ngày
này năm nay thì đã sống sót được bao
nhiêu ngày bởi vì mấy ông thì ra tổ
không biết rồi mấy ông sinh từ giờ bao
nhiêu phút thì bao nhiêu dài bao nhiêu
thôi Làm cái này tôi đã khá nhiều ông
từng kiểu ngồi lên đếm đến đến Sắp đến
sinh nhật mình đấy được chưa ạ đừng mua
cái sinh nhật mình
thứ hai mà
tiếp theo là hiển thị ra là điểm danh
của bản thân Điểm danh các thứ ở Hồi đấy
Tối còn làm thống kê bên này nhiều anh
nhưng mà tôi tắt bớt thì phải nhờ tôi có
cái Menu
ông ngoại tôi có menu ẩn bớt đi ấy à Mày
nó bự này còn dài hơn làm nhiều lắm để
đợi thì
à à
đề kiểm tra môn chưa nhập điểm đây này
Đấy đúng rồi Tôi làm nhiều lắm
A là
đề kiểm tra môn nào chưa được nhập điểm
Đấy là sử thi lâu rồi mà chưa nhập này
xong rồi à lập sách lập danh sách khi
lần một là lập danh sách sinh dự thi lại
này bởi vì là sử những cái đứa mà chơi
được thì lạ á chơi thì Vân bột hoặc k bị
cấm thi lần 1 thì sẽ chỉ ra này xót danh
sách thi à Và thậm chí còn hiển thị ra
sinh viên phải học lại nữa
ở Cộng hòa thương nhớ cái này còn nhiều
có vụ chăm sóc sinh viên thông báo toàn
bộ tất cả sinh viên này thông báo này
hồi đấy con gửi qua Cẩm nhóm trên
Facebook này
Khi nào Thôi xem tình hình trên cần để
hiển thị ra là là à
một số buổi đi học của
từ khóa nhưng mà mùa này hình như là à
gần đây là phải nghe thành ra không đến
chị
thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra đây để nhắc nhở để
mà phù hợp cho giáo vụ có thể gọi nhắc
nhở sinh viên đi nhưng cái này tôi nhớ
là hình như à
hình như là tôi ẩn nó đi rồi nữa sẽ
tôi ấn nó đi rồi
chị xem sinh viên thi lại và học lại này
anh nhiều lắm rồi tôi làm nhiều Cực
huề Tôi không biết câu chữ chưa vẫn theo
kiểu là làm theo kiểu lê quần lắm nhưng
tôi làm hết quần bằng word vì nó rất là
nặng
a ha anh đang là sinh viên à
Anh
không biết nói câu này nha Ờ đây sinh
viên khóa theo lớp cái vừa nãy tôi bảo
đấy vậy Thuận đi cô sinh viên được Khoa
theo lớp này có thể nhập và
bạn có thể thêm bằng Excel này cập nhật
và cái xe này chuyển lớp cho sinh viên
này à
Em in địa điểm đủ kiểu đấy thống kê Này
thống kê tình trạng đi học thống kê đi
học này hiểu Quý khùng
xe tải
cho trẻ 2 tháng gần nhất thì chả có
12 tháng gần nhất
alo PC phiên bản cũ ở tp phiên bản cũ
thì cài giấu giấu giấu mạnh có thể ghi
kiểu là là hoặc ghét tao ngọn gái được
không không cho nữa đấy mới tới làm
nhiều hơn hỏi tôi làm nhiều hơn
ờ ờ
Ok em còn đại khái thì bên sinh viên thì
nó hiển thị ra là mình đã được à Mình đã
biết điểm danh những buổi nào những môn
đang học là gìmôn chọc gì môn đã học ở
gì thi là như nào Cá thứ thì chị ra các
giáo viên đã từng dậy mình để gọi điện
để Spam là ngã đấy thống kê nghỉ học của
bản thân anh cưỡng thế xem mình có phải
học trò gương mẫu hay không Hãy cậu như
thế
vừa rồi tôi nói qua về việc là một cái
trang web
chỉ cần ngược Khoe nhiều hơn nhưng mà
ông cũng hình dung được là một trang web
khi mình nhập rất nhiều cái vào thì thực
sự thì
Hồ Ngọc Trinh
Ừ cái phần nhập ấy nói ít còn cái phần
mà để mà phân tích để mà thống kê để mà
kẹo xuất ta để nó tiện người dùng heo
rất là nhiều loại không thấy nút đấy tôi
bị dùng class Nó hiểu nhầm mà nút đấy
hiển thị thông báo thằng này đã bỏ học
mà chứ không phải với nút đâu
em
lấy hiện bị tình trạng đang đi học hay
đang bỏ học mà
ờ ờ
chạm nhiều con strong were không không
gọi tôi chẳng đụng thì mấy trong con phi
trong our gặp hồi đấy à tối thử hơi kém
để chuyên sâu fragile bởi vì hồi đấy gần
như cốt vẫn là tê thuần là nhiều hơn
anh có phân tích ra trước rồi hài cốt
luôn nó sẽ bao gồm cả hai đấy bởi vì tôi
bảo là thầy của tôi Hồi trước thấy có
tầm nhìn thấy là bí đây thì thấy sẽ sẽ
luôn phân tích và trước cái đề cho tôi
để tôi hình dung sau đó tôi lại phân
tích của tôi tôi phải mấy ông phải hiểu
ở trong tôi đấy có phải năm sáu chục tờ
A4 số tôi sẽ ngồi luôn lấy cái buồn ta
để vẽ các phone cái tình đang quan trọng
Đấy với luôn này vẽ lên trong phone để
lại hình dung được bài toán mà cần phải
có giao diện như nào nút như là bấm như
thế nào Bấm vào cái này thì chị là cái
gì Vớ vẩn đấy Sau đó thì mới bắt đầu cốt
Nói chung là tôi phân tích phải đến chán
chê được rồi ban đầu cốt đấy do tôi
khuyên mày ông phải làm kiểu như thế Bây
giờ lên nhà tao không thể chuẩn bị mấy
ông lấy bút được chứ hồi mà tôi chạy
sinh viên tôi bác sinh viên không ma em
chỉ mang bút giấy lên thôi
giấy đôi khi rộn chuẩn bị bút khi Dậu
mua cho sinh viên tôi Trích tiền nó già
từ mua sinh viên chỉ chỉ lên lớp chị
ngồi vẽ rồi mẹ
anh ngồi vẽ cậu vẽ con cá thứ để mà thực
sự hình dung tôi duyệt cái phone đấy thì
bắt được bắt đầu được làm à
hỏi cái hay cái nó so sánh thấy được bản
chất là cái nào tôi thấy à cái gì bây
giờ còn đang hiện hành năng sử dụng ấy
thì cần đi là nó có lý do nào cả Không ạ
Ừ nó nghĩ à
thôi Tôi nghĩ là kiểu mỗi tháng có một
thế mạnh riêng ông phải hiểu được thế
mạnh nó đã và ông dùng ông trùm những
trường hợp nào đã dụng làm cái web như
vừa tồi nên là axwell còn nếu mà làm
theo cậu dạng là dữ liệu cực kì lớn và
ông không Ông muốn nó rất là nhanh nó
không nó không kiểu dạng là nó không cần
chặt chẽ có thể sai sót hơn gì đó thì có
thể mogo gì đó Nói chung là dữ liệu cực
kì lớn thì mới mong vô mở ra nói cái gì
Ờ tôi học Tao chỉ chị một khoảng thời
gian thôi Vì tôi biết mô hình mới xe ô
pê rồi
Ừ nhưng mà tôi thực hành khá nhiều cho
lĩnh khi kiểu làm chính thức làm cái
trang web vừa rồi và trong lúc chào làm
cho web vừa rồi Thực ra tôi vẫn làm
tsabelle rất là tệ nếu mấy ông để kỹ cố
tôi rất là tệ về lo quần độn cho nó rõ
rất nhiều cái chưa rõ hồi nãy tôi bị
chảy rì ghép lại rất là nhiều thành ra
là cốt PT của tôi về cơ bản thì là ổn
nhưng còn Eriol gì không Tao đèo tôi hồi
nãy đẩy cực Nói chung là tôi à
mà tôi không biết bài bếp mà ở đây cũng
lười làm bài viết này không à trong làm
mực mọi thứ tiên đối không biết hyper là
gì này nhiều cái nhìn nhìn controllo rất
là dài tôi rất dài ấy fear có thừa sự
rất là vầy chung là tôi không Ừ tôi thì
chỉ em nói là về cái bài toán nghiệp vụ
Tôi đã từng sự lý được có vẻ tạm ổn thôi
chứ còn với cốt của tôi hồi đấy là cô
tôi rất là non ở chung và gần như à thực
ra Bình cũng mình cũng bởi vì là tôi à
anh đi à
Tôi đi thực tập ở đúng một chỗ tầm 6
tháng sau đó thì tôi về dậy luôn nên hai
nha Tôi cũng không có nhiều kinh nghiệm
lắm để mà kiểu
ở đây mà học hỏi được thêm người khác
toàn tự làm tự học
anh chủ yếu thôi không và cũng chẳng ai
có review cốt mình để để biết được Có
mình đang tệ hệ đàn hay cả thực thế nên
là tôi mới nghỉ dạy học bởi việc về sau
rồi Đúng là tôi có tốt hơn rồi tôi tự
mày mò lao nhèo tự mệt mỏi que để cốc
tốt hơn rồi nhưng mà
anh vẫn phải muốn ra ngoài va chạm gì mà
thực sự khi mình biết được là mình đăng
đang ở ngưỡng như nào đúng ạ Thế là tôi
mới kiểu nhi dậy để mà tôi đi làm ở công
ty ở bên ngoài
phết năm mấy ông nhà gọi không biết sáng
mai gì không
à à
có
bí quyết nào Có tốt hơn không bí quyết
thì ta đơn giản lắm đầu tiên à đầu tiên
là thứ nhất là bởi vì mấy ông đều là mới
nên thành ra là cậu mấy ông cư cũng nghĩ
cách để giải quyết một vấn đề một vài
toàn đi đã không ạ Rồi khi mà giờ giải
quyết được rồi thì mấy ông sẽ cân nhắc
không việc ạ Bạn này có thể tối ưu được
không Ngoài việc Là tối ưu Thì hãy nên
cân nhắc cả việc là đoạn này có dễ đọc
hay không dễ hiểu hay không người khác
có thể dễ hiểu được đại đế không Dạo này
về sau có dễ sửa những chỗ nào đúng ạ
tôi tôi thường anh lấy cái ví dụ như thế
này tôi thường này lấy ví dụ như này nhá
đó là sự ngay đi giả sử ra sự nhé là ờ ờ
đầu tiên là mình sẽ điểm bằng
em
inbox nhập vào này à
Khi so sánh điểm thế mà điểm lớn hơn 5
Ừ thì à mình sẽ
in ra là Đạt không ạ
ạ
Và nếu không thì mình sẽ in ra là
anh không đạt không ạ
Mấy ông Khi mà xem được cả ngưỡng như
này rồi thì mày cũng sẽ hiểu thừa sức
hiểu được cái đoạn này nó đơn giản như
nào đâu ạ
Nhưng bây giờ tôi sẽ biệt đội nó theo
cậu mức của lĩnh vực cao hơn một tí thôi
nhá
họ sẽ nha
thì đầu tiên cái này nhiên nó chả thay
đổi thì mấy nhà mình có thể sửa lại là
điểm nhập vào nếu mà đặt tên sẽ điểm
nhập vào nha chồng ạ
em về nó rõ nghĩa ra
a cho dù tên biến hệ dài hơn đúng không
ạ tiếp theo cái này là cái điều kiện để
mà kiểm tra xem là bà hay không đặt đúng
ạ thì mình sẽ tạo ra một cái hàm riêng
là hả kiểm tra bạn
trả về kiểm tra xem Đạt hay không đạt
như này Em có vào đây mình sẽ đặt tên
như này đó Tên mình hiểu được mà
đó là vì sau khi mình muốn sửa cái điều
kiện Ví dụ mình sửa điều kiện là
62 là phải thêm một cái điều kiện gì đó
nữa ở trong này chẳng hạn thế Nhưng mình
chỉ cần cập nhật ở đây là chỗ này nó sẽ
không bị tác động gì cả nó chưa nhỏ cốt
ra kiểu như thế này chiếc pháo nữa đó là
mấy ông hệ quý ốc xem là điểm đạt
đó là hằng số lúc này mình sẽ thể cho
một cái điểm đạt ở đây
bằng năm nha Sau đó mình chỉ cần truyền
điểm đạt vào trong nha
Tiếp theo nữa đó là mình thấy là cái
phần
a.quy này thử tà Cả hai đều gọi đến Hàm
Green cùng ngọn và cốt để nó chỉ khác
nhau ở mỗi cái thông báo ạ thì mình sẽ
làm như sau như thể
à à anh đọc báo
sau đó thì
I should have print nội dung trở lại
ngay Giả sử ra sự nhà nhé sự là đây đây
là bởi vì ông ông đang làm mỗi quý thì
cả ông chỉ có mỗi ngắn nhất là thôi ngỡ
đầu về sao ông làm những cái xử lý nóng
nó ghê gớm hơn ở đây và ghi gồm hơn ở
đây thì ông hoàn toàn là có thể gọi cái
hàm là chạy khi đạt cho bạn
thì tại sao không Vứt vào trong như này
à
nhiều thành những cái nhỏ hơn nhìn trong
lúc đầu có vẻ hơi khó chịu đấy Tôi thề
tôi nhìn vào lúc đầu khó chịu cực kiểm
nghiệm ngay đúng không
à nho thực tế thực tế nhá làm với ông
nên chia nhỏ từng tăng trưởng quá chừng
này ra thay vì cốt của ông sẽ rất là dài
trong một cái phóng sinh họ sẽ khó là
khuôn nhiều âm Hạnh như cái sự Alo nó sẽ
chia nhỏ nhỏ ra nha
đấy Đây là cách làm của Suneo con nếu
Man Junior vừa mới vào ấy Chắc là chỉ có
mỗi mình cái dòng đầu như vừa nãy ra
xong đấy à
điểm đó là kiểu khi mà chưa nhỏ như thế
thì thì dễ học thật đấy nhưng nó lại bị
dài quá thành ra dài thì nó lại bị ngược
với cái việc dễ lập
Ừ nếu hiểu ạ bởi vì dễ nạp thì nhưng mà
nó khó nhớ ngọn cái này ra là mấy cái
đấy mấy ông nên cân nhắc Bởi vì tôi đã
từng bản thân chính tôi và rất nhiều anh
em cũng thường ngày giờ cái bẫy đó là
cốt sao cho có vẻ chuyên nghiệp
đó là cậu luôn luôn nghĩ rằng là đoạn
đoạn này mình phải nén tối ưu đoạn này
phải lên Nên làm trưng nhật bạn này nên
phải sửa lại với Vân Thành ra ở chúng ta
có quanh củ Ly quanh của loại những cái
tính năng mà rõ vào nó thực sự là nó chỉ
cần làm vài vài tiếng ở xong thay vì đó
mình mất tật 3 4 ngày chị ngồi làm những
cái đấy Sao vậy Sao mình chẳng thay đổi
gì đấy cả mình nghĩ là vì sao mình có
thể thay đổi nhưng mình sẽ nhờ động mẹ
nó
Ừ thì thì anh em chở và anh em cũng bị
rơi ở trong nước đấy Đó là cầm một tối
ưu á Mỗi tối yêu quá xong rồi cuối cùng
nhận ra là mình mất cả buổi Chị ngồi làm
mỗi cái tính năng máy tí đó cũng chẳng
phải tính năng quan trọng cái trang web
do mình mất quá nhiều thời gian cho nó
Em nghe anh em có bị hạn chế bị rơi cái
vụ đấy Hồi trước là tôi cũng hay bị thế
suốt và anh ở công ty anh có nói
anh em biết tại sao bây giờ Xiaomi nó
đang nổi lên như giờ
Ê thằng iPhone nó nổi lên
thì giá này không nói như Xiaomi bây giờ
gần đang đang nổi lên bởi vì ạ đó giá rẻ
không ạ đánh vào
chị
đánh là 80 phần trăm
ở thị trường người dùng
và nó chị tốn 20 phần trăm
còn nhiều các bài toán 20 80 trí nhớ nó
là như nào nhỉ
dạng là bánh mặt 8 à
vợ hay như nào rồi Ờ
nó hết rồi nhưng đại khái đại phải đó là
đúng rồi đúng rồi đại khái nói như thế
này nó kiểu ông có thể ông ông làm 80
phần trăm công việc đó rất là nhanh
ở những cái kiểu những cái tính năng vừa
đã ý tôi cho miếng xem là những cái tính
năng cơ bản khóa mươi phần trăm tám mươi
phần trăm của trang web này sẽ rất nhanh
nhưng hai mươi phần trăm vào lại những
cái nâng cao ấy thì bị ông sẽ làm rất là
lâu và thời gian của nó sẽ gấp đôi gấp 4
lần so với thời gian làm cái kia nghĩa
cái bản chất là
Ừ ông ông mất thời gian tập 80 phần trăm
cho cái cả 20 phần trăm mà ít người dùng
ít người dùng
khi giết người cậu xuống đến nhưng mà nó
lại rất là quan trọng ấy cận như thế Hay
mình như thế ông có thể tập trung mà ở
hướng vào cái 80 phần trăm hơn là hai
phần trăm này ấy chẳng hạn thế
có cây khế
tôi thử sữa thôi cũng không Lát được thì
bạn hình dung được câu nói văn vở của
anh ấy đã từng nói là gì Đại Khánh thì
nếu không nên tốn quá nhiều thời gian để
tối ưu làm một cái gì đó Mẹ của chị hồi
trước của tôi từng tổ giặt 3 buồn tháng
cũng ngồi làm đi làm lại một cái vô
trách soi xong rồi anh ấy bỏ loa kiểu em
hả thời gian này em làm ba bốn cái bozak
mà mỗi cặp forex tiến bộ hơn từng ngày
còn hơn là việc là em làm đi làm lại một
cái
nên cách để cải thiện code của mấy ông
ấy đó là mấy ông không phải cứ ngày nào
cũng ngồi xem lại code cũ để mấy ông
nghĩ nâng cấp nó mày mày ông có thể làm
hẳn cái mới xong rồi dựa theo kinh
nghiệm cũ của mấy ông để để sửa cái mới
nó hoàn thiện Thế là được rồi
mại điện tử hay tin tức nghỉ không hiểu
ý của ông lắm
đi xây lại anh Trọng ngày nào khi ra tù
ấy bởi vì nếu nâng cấp gói của bản thân
mình cốt thì tự nhiên mình dễ Còn nếu mà
giờ sự cốt người khác thì đúng là một
năm đi xe lại thật vì ngồi đọc hiểu cốt
người khác tốn quá nhiều thời gian ở
không dùng của Vertu của trước mình có
dùng minor để mà khách không thôi à
nhiều quá Có cách nào cân bằng giữa việc
suy nghĩ cốt với Tìm Google không
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
cái này tôi nghĩa là bản thân mình phải
cân nhắc được à mình hỏi cân bằng được
gỡ vụ là là tự học với kiểu dạng là
thuộc chủ động hay chủ động ấy nghĩa làm
chị ơi ông đừng có phụ thuộc hơi thì tra
mọi Google mà nên Cậu dặn mà nên nghĩ
bài toán trước đã
Ừ nếu cứ quy ước hẳn một khoảng thời
gian nào đó nghĩ về đoán trước đã rồi
ông cha và cha xong thì mấy ông cũng tra
xong có thể nếu Cốc Cốc về nó chạy được
luôn Nhưng mày cũng phải xem lại Tại sao
lại chạy được thì dần dần nóng sẽ quen
được việc tư duy lôgic cũng như học hỏi
được những người khác thôi mình không
lại bảo thủ ở cậu không cần cha Google
vẫn thể làm được thì đôi khi ở người ta
làm những cái cốt nó tối ưu hơn ở những
cái ngon hơn rồi những dòng mỹ được rồi
chúng bọn mình không học họ được thì
mình sai nhưng mà nếu mình bị phụ thuộc
quá thì về sau mà cha không có gì thì
mình lại chịu khó nói ông Cân bằng kiểu
thế thôi
vụ bí quyết chống đau lưng tôi hiện tại
đến bây giờ tôi vẫn rất là may mắn Tôi
chưa bị đau lưng khi mà ngồi nhiều mà
trong khi đó tôi ngồi chơi game hẹn mọi
thứ nghe hết
Ê bà mai mà Bây giờ tôi đang ngồi cái
hiện tại tao câu nói Học cậu công ty trợ
là khẳng định công ty rồi tại chợ từ
Iris Vãi thì
Ừ chắc là tôi Nghĩa Ông có thể mua về
câu nói Học để tham khảo
nghĩ âm
vụ áp lực của hai cái khác nhau điểm nào
ạ
Ờ Ờ
mình thấy ở bây giờ đi học nó bị bệnh
thành tích và lẫn cả là vì cái bìa học ở
đại học chính quy nó còn liên quan việc
và vì cái suy nghĩ người khác nhiều hơn
về bản thân mình thật sự đấy rất nhiều
bạn bây giờ đang học đại học là kiểu vì
cậu bố mẹ độ bố mẹ cho tiền mình phải
học này không muốn làm phụ lòng bố mẹ
này không muốn làm mất mặt trước mặt bạn
bè thì mình Mình bỏ học hay mình kiểu gì
chưa thay gì đó hơn là thực sự mình muốn
theo cái ngành này không Hay muốn thực
sự học cái môn thế không đấy tôi Nghĩa
phải bỏ qua được những cái tư tưởng này
đã con áp lực của việc đi làm thì thực
ra là nó chỉ trở về đồng tiền nhiều hơn
chứ không ngoại về kiểu người khác đánh
giá mình mấy nữa
nghe tôi nghĩa đấy Nó là một hai á một
cái
chán không ạ
ờ ờ
Ừ ông áp dụng ý ông ở ngôn ngữ lập trình
thì ông cứ áp dụng ngôn ngữ lập trình
thấy làm cái gì đó thì ông sẽ không làm
chán thôi còn nếu mà ông cứ chỉ ngồi đọc
tài liệu thì không ai khẳng định được
ông sẽ ông ông bảo ông dùng từ nhàm chán
đối với ông thế nào nhàm chán đã không ạ
Ông bảo đọc lý thuyết nhiều nhàm chán
ông ạ Ông bảo ông đọc đọc nhiều nhàm
chán thì ông cũng hình dung được cả thế
nào nhàm chán rồi ông ạ Cái ông chỉ việc
thay đổi cái đấy một đã thay đổi là
không không đọc lý thuyết nữa mà không
áp dụng thực hành luôn hay là ông phải
thay đổi quan điểm đó là học lý thuyết
không nhận chán ông chọn một trong hai
ông thấy cái nào rẻ hơn không ạ ạ
đại phải gì à tôi muốn hôm nay tôi sẽ
chia sẻ mẹ đấy hi vọng chữ cá ngón các
nhóm đồ án đang làm thì có thể tham khảo
tham khảo Cái cái cái buồn mà tôi vừa
làm và tôi vừa trình bày nữa Tôi vừa
trình bày để mà các bạn có thể cấu hình
dung được hôm bảo vệ bảo vệ trình bày
như nào cũng như là nên làm một cái sản
phẩm bài toán nghiệp vụ nó phải như thế
nào không ạ phải xử lý như thế nào đấy
quản lý các thử thứ
phát sóng mẹ khỏi Apple rồi thì chữ cái
à Ông có thể học với cấu trúc dữ liệu và
giải thuật Nói chung là Maxwell chuyên
sau ashworth g đủ và uống nó hợp thêm
cái đấy thôi đã cả về kiểu BIG data kiểu
gửi thế học thêm thôi
tới hiện tại thì có thể làm phim Lancer
được không ô ồ Cô khuyên là là mấy ông
giống như cái trang web vừa làm Nó gần
như một phiên show vì nó dựa theo kinh
nghiệm của hiện tại nhưng mà dự thử Tôi
tự làm thôi Nhưng mà mấy ông thầy Đấy nó
nó không có một cái tổ chức gì cả nó
không chuyên nghiệp có vẫn còn thuộc về
tôi yêu cầu kinh nghiệm thì ông cũng nên
như thế nghĩa mấy ông nên đi làm bảo vệ
công ty để cho nó hình dung được cái sự
chuyên nghiệp
hai cách hiểu thứ học họ cho người khác
đi đã
Ừ khi nào ổn thì về sau làm phiên sớm
được mà
một phần ông ông nói có đúng nhá Bởi vì
tôi tôi hội cho tôi mua cái khóa học
xong rồi đến chính là tác giả larger của
nói là cái ông làm ra khóa học này còn
hiểu Lara hơn của ông đấy
rất là sao nghĩa là ông kia đã tự mày mò
tự Đọc cốt để mà hiểu chứ không phải là
ngồi đọc tài liệu của Kệ ông viết tác
giả nào viết Bởi vì nếu tác nếu mà đọc
tài liệu thì làm theo đúng tài liệu thì
chả có gì để mà tạo ra khóa mới nó không
ạ Bây giờ có rất nhiều khóa học Lazio ở
gần như là của vì À bởi vì a tài liệu
của nó đứng như là có đây nhờ có nhưng
mà nó cứ kiểu nó không sự là
anh tâm sự không được sự là hay và 01 sự
đó cậu dễ hiểu để làm nó bị nhiều nhưng
mà cũng dối mày không hiểu thì thôi à
Ừ anh Tuấn chia sẻ tôi tôi quyền sử mất
rồi thì thôi
thì thôi sẽ nhắn hỏi lại anh đấy Ờ
Cho tôi mua nhiều khóa phết đấy mà ông
khỏe tối mùa khóa học của tôi muốn
khi mẹ cho bé uống kém khóa của tôi đã
học vậy
tải này rồi này rồi đấy thôi
ừ ừ
vài cái nó miễn phí không nói tôi mới
mua được cả một hai ba cái
ở nhà đấy ở bên bên bên espace này tôi
có mua ở bên tái cái bồ đã
tại cái bồ tôi cũng mua
em phải yêu thích cái văn hóa thì ngại
văn hóa Mọi thứ cái điểm lợi khi mà học
tiếng Anh đã chứ không nghệ bảo là em dụ
Giả sử bây giờ bảo tôi Chích cái ngôn
ngữ lập trình chả không thích đâu Nhưng
mà Bởi vì nó đem lại mình rất nhiều thứ
mình thích thôi
Mở bài tôi mua thì ba khó ông ngoại nữa
này không Rồi tôi còn loại khóa của anh
Tuấn chia sẻ nữa
Nokia Note II s có phải con ty vận
chuyển mà À hôm trước mà em bảo tôi này
có 12 năm kinh nghiệm tôi không rõ nhưng
mà kiểu gì mà trong tiền
Em
học cái này xong quên cái kia tớ thực tế
là kiểu Thứ nhất là tôi không biết tôi
biết được là khá nhiều ông kiểu dạng là
nói chung các bạn đa số chung thì đương
nhiên vẫn hay quên có việc sau bị Coffee
chẳng ạ ấy thì hôi hôi bé thôi lại cậu
thích chơi mấy cái trò luyện trí nhớ
không biết mấy ông cười đam mê giống tôi
hộ bé không bảo cậu rất thích hay chơi
mấy trò luyện trí nhớ và tôi thường anh
xem lại những cái cũ Xem phim cũ trên
lại ngay nhạc cụ rất thứ đấy là một cách
để màn hình dung việc là mình sẽ sôi
chuốt xâu chuỗi lại những cái cứu những
cái cũ cái ở trong làm sao cho nhớ
luyện khả năng ở đây mếu phải phân biệt
nhé đối với tôi con điện nhé Thì não
mình nó sẽ có kiểu là bản chất là não
mình sẽ luôn ghi nhớ tất cả những cái
đấy Mình không quên cái đấy đâu nhưng mà
mình
khi truy xuất dữ liệu giống như kiểu
hình dung và máy tính máy tính của ông
bây giờ não của ông giống như con siêu
máy tính ở thế Lưu lại tất cả chứ không
phải có chuyện mà nó bị đầy bộ nhiều nó
không bị không lưu lại nữa nó phải Xóa
bớt đi không không phải như thế họ vẫn
sẽ lưu lại tất cả nhưng mà Cái quan
trọng là bây giờ Làm thế nào để ông Ông
tìm lại được những cái file cũ không tin
lại những cái gì ở cũ thì thì ông không
phải nâng cấp não rồi mà mình trận đấy
đúng không Thì ông sẽ phải làm quen việc
và ông làm quen với việc và ông truy
xuất dữ liệu
cho não là nó là làm theo kiểu là ông
làm cái gì ở càng nhiều lần thì nó sẽ
càng quen với việc đấy và làm cái việc
đánh nhanh hơn thế nên là việc truy xuất
dữ liệu ký ức truy sát Ký ức những lấy
lại những cái cũ Ông làm cái việc đấy
thông xuyên thì não sẽ quen việc à chị
lấy lại thiếu thường xuyên và nhanh nó
không hiểu Tôi không ạ tại thế nên là
bây giờ Ông bảo là ông thường xuyên nhớ
lại những cái gì cũ dần dần dần ông sẽ
bị quay nó việc à Bây giờ giống như tôi
tưởng tôi nhớ được nhiều cái lắm ra
nhiều cái không hay sự nghiệp vẫn nhớ là
đã thế Cái gì à Mình quen việc
Ngài nói chung Xem lại những cái cũ với
các hư thứ tương tự thế khi mà Mấy ông
tiếp xúc quá nhiều cái mới của ông chỉ
tập trung cái mới thôi ông quen đi Không
kệ cái cũ nha Bây giờ ông chú ra lại cái
cũ nó hơi khó thế thôi
cho học tiếng Anh thì toàn bộ những cái
tiếng Anh tôi đọc Thủy Tôi thấy được K
Ừ mình nên không sợ nó mình không nên sợ
mình làm quen với nó hàng ngày có rất
nhiều cái tôi không dịch được nó hẳn ra
đâu nó tôi gặp nó tiếp xúc nói nhiều thì
hình dung được Nam đã Ừ nó nó nó có phải
là nghĩa nhìn thế này phải và đặc biệt
tài liệu tiếng Anh của ngày này chứ k0
mà nó khó lắm chỉ quanh quẩn những từ
khóa thôi à
Xin chào Google nói chuyện liên quan
những cái từ khóa đấy thật ra không khó
đâu
càng học mà ông càng thấy mình biết hết
rồi thì giống thỏ ông học sai rồi
api là gì
và khóa lario anh đã dậy chưa ạ api là
gì Sữa thì bây giờ tôi vẫn không biết
giải thích thế nào cho mấy ông họ văn Vợ
dễ hiểu để bộ sau đi còn khóa La đây ăn
thì mình nóng dậy rồi đấy chứ Mình đang
dậy rồi mà mình đang trong Đã vậy mà
gửi lâu nó là mô hình cái này phải cả
nó có thêm nhiều cái nữa p thuần nghỉ
thì có cái gì để mà phát triển máy đâu
để tìm tòi mới đâu ạ Khi nào ông tìm
hiểu của cái Facebook không phải để mà
chuyên được Facebook đấy không đầu mà là
kiểu sẽ còn nữa để mở Tăng cái khả năng
tìm tòi tăng khả năng ứng biến của ông
để mà Ông Ông sắp xếp tổ chức cái cốt
như thế nào Còn nếu mà ông không muốn
theo phím gốc khi ông bắt buộc vẫn theo
một cái mô hình ở đó để cốt nó chuyên
nhiệt không phải cốt thuần là vẫn chưa
toàn bộ hết trong file thì không được
em chẳng biết dùng từ đấy như thế nào
tôi sẽ tôi có dạy về api rồi mà còn dạy
viết api không biết cái nên nó nhà ấy
trông thế nào dạy viết à
ừ ừ
Anh chỉ là selects các thử cho mà
à à
ở
bảng xếp hạng bội Hôm nay thật ra hơn 1
tiếng đấy chắc là tạm này cho Google thì
ông cũng phải đang xúng đang
Ừ ừ đúng rồi quên không thông báo là sắp
đến 10 người đăng ký rồi Có bạn bảo là
ký quay đi nhưng mà tôi chẳng biết được
tôi sẽ giúp đâu gì thì mình không có cái
gì cả Tôi còn đang nợ tiền tôi còn đang
đang phải xin ứng lương
em
vừa rồi xin được 13 triệu để mà trả tiền
nhà với Tin học
khi sinh thường luôn tháng sau đấy nên
lên là sao trên rồi Huawei nghỉ cho
giveaway mỗi việc ông bốn cô Kelly Cafe
Cao mì ông cũng được đấy à
mấy ông thấy thực tế bây giờ
anh không thấy thực tế bây giờ là Ờ đang
có trên 100 người xe nhưng thực ra tôi
không quan tâm về cái số lượng cảm ơn
người số lượng người xem lắm đâu ngờ tôi
ăn từng nói nếu là sử mà tự nhiên số
lượng người xem dài ra mà chứng tỏ mình
có vấn đề thê thảm
họa Mày kệ mày cái đều lấy được nhưng mà
vẫn đang trên đà tăng trưởng người ta
mình thấy vẫn có gì đó Mình vẫn đang làm
đúng nên phải ra vẫn vui à
anh đã tự nhiên vợ lên 6 mấy rồi à
Ồ tôi định về 6 viết sách mà không phải
biết sách lập trình mà tôi với sách về
cuộc đời rồi
ở phía sau nếu bao giờ sử mà tôi thất
tình tôi không ai yêu tôi sẽ vừa quyết
sách đúng kiểu dạng là một chàng hotboy
này về cuộc đời tôi để mà
sẽ cho tới trái hạn
ra cả đây tôi lấy ý tưởng từ hôm trước
thì đập cái ở trên diễn đàn và R2 Nghe
kể chuyện đấy ngày nữa hư cấu nửa thật
nếu mà Mấy ông đọc rồi chúng đến em đấy
rồi ông sẽ biết cái biệt danh đấy Đó là
Lãng tử đa tình Alo đám cưới cô độc ạ
à à
không phải xoay quanh mỗi cái chuyện đấy
cuộc đời tôi có ý nghĩa là nó cũng li kì
ấm Bởi đã từng kể cho vài người chỉ phải
người có vẻ và 2 túi xách đi vào việc 6
tuổi định là Nguyên Xá thật
anh
không biết phân tích cơ sở dữ liệu thì
làm bác em có ổn không Các thoải mái
miễn là bạn không cần động vào cơ sở
liệu nhiều thôi đôi khi là có người khác
làm thay bạn vụ đấy mà
vợ đi làm ở thế nào
hồi mà mình đi học thì trường của mình
là trường Nghề ấy thì nghe rất thoải mái
nghĩa khi mình phải đi làm đấy thì
trường cho nghỉ luôn không cần phải đi
học nữa anh thật là mình không biết phân
bố như thế nào nó hợp lý
xe Honda các bạn khác thì cho nhiều các
bạn có vì thôi tôi chẳng thấy bố gì cả
Chỉ có tôi có vòng đeo hội cho tim và
tháng tháng 10 này thì sẽ
sẽ bày trong Sài Gòn đấy chị sẽ có kiểu
people were những cái đầu đồ ấn ấn phẩm
của dự tim thôi vòng tay cá hư hướng
mày có đi không bán mà không ạ
à Xong rồi phải sang năm đầu năm sau có
thể trước Tết hay sau Tết thì ấy sẽ
offline ở Đà Nẵng với dự định là như thế
chưa biết đi nha Còn tháng 10 này tôi cứ
tạm chốt à là offline chứ nhưng tim ở
Sài Gòn đã
ạ con ở Hà Nội cho ca là anh em ở Hà Nội
đang đi tạm đi đâu ấy nói chung là tôi
Ừ nhưng mà tôi cũng sẽ cần nhanh việc là
tổ chức sang năm sau năm nay tôi cũng bị
gì rất nhiều rồi nên không chuẩn bị được
hết à
anh không cùng lắm là tháng 10 sang năm
thì mới bắt đầu offline ở Hà Nội vậy
không à
em làm đồ ăn thịt đâu có dùng ấy ve từ
đâu ở nhà không lắm mà dùng mỗi grab.api
để mà làm cái việc là đẩy
tự động tự động đăng bài lên các nhóm
thôi
nhỉ người Ông còn hỏi việc không có bữa
hôm nay tặng ngừng đây nha Thôi nghỉ đi
nghỉ ngơi xa đã
mấy ông thể chém gió sau nha Sao thầy
biết người thư viện thế đó tôi mỏ nhiều
à thực ra biết nhiều không bạn đâu chẳng
qua hơn đúng mấy ông thôi chứ rất nhiều
người biết hơn
thôi chẳng qua thì đáng lẽ mình cũng
nghĩ có nghĩ ý tưởng sao mình cứ tra
Google xe mà đã có những cái Pocket đã
những có những cái gì làm dựa trên cái
này chưa xong rồi rồi nhau cũng xem tham
khảo ở một vài nguồn kiểu với tạm giới
thiệu nhưng cái Pocket khác thứ thứ Ừ
thì biết thôi
Xin chào mấy ông nhé